you mentioned kind of
the ups and downs of life and the
midlife crisis
and right now you said focusing kind of
on the journey
but what the journey involves is ups and
downs
is there advice
or any kind of thoughts that you can
elucidate
about the downs in your life
yeah the hard parts of your life and
how you got out or maybe not or
is there yeah how do you see the dark
parts
yeah of life so i i'm so glad you're
asking this question because
it's something that our society does a
terrible job at preparing us for
every hollywood movie has to have a
happy ending
it is ridiculous you can count on your
10 fingers the number of
bad ending movies that you've ever
watched and you probably wouldn't need
all ten fingers
yeah we strive to tell everyone
yes you can succeed yes
you're a millionaire just temporarily
disabled
and yes you know uh
the prince will eventually figure out
his princess and they will have
a happily ever after ending and
yes the hero will be beaten and beat and
beaten but you know that at the end of
the movie the good eyes will win
we need more movies where the bad guys
win we need more movies where just
everybody dies
we're just you know a macgyver doesn't
figure out how to disable the bomb and
just explodes
you just you just need more movies that
are more realistic about the fact that
life kind of sucks sometimes and it's
okay
so again growing up in greece i
have been exposed to songs that are not
just
sad but they're miserable
miserable so so one of them one of them
comes to mind
and and it's it's basically talking
about this woman
who's lamenting in the early morning
about losing the joyful kid
the joyful young man who basically died
in the civil war in the arms
of our own fellow citizens
and she's like if only he had died
fighting the foreign forces if only he
had died
at the you know sides of the you know
general if only he had died with honor
i would be proud to have lost the joyful
kid
i mean it's devastating right it's like
he didn't just die he died without honor
yeah and and my friend who was with me
was listening to this song and she's
like this is depressing i'm like
you have to listen to another one it's
not assad and she's like what this one
died with honor
[Laughter]
so so that that's one example it's a
kind of a celebration
of uh misery no no no no no no no so let
me give you a couple more examples and
then i'll answer that question so
another example is
i i picked up this book that i had from
my childhood and i started reading
stories to my kids and the first story
is about
these two children one is really poor
living on the street
and the other one is really rich living
in the house and the bright light above
and the poor one is wishing looking in
that window and wishing that you could
have that house
and the other one is at the window
wishing that he was free
that he wasn't sick all the time that
you could escape outside
it's only four pages long and at the end
both children die
one of them dies from cold the other one
dies from illness
and you're like how is that even a
children's story
the next story i'm like okay that's fine
let's skip this one let's you know so i
read this to my kids and then i read the
next one
and the next one is about this this
woman whose
brother is at war against the turks
and he is gonna die
and she prays to the virgin please don't
let him die
and the virgin appears and she's like no
problem tell me who to kill instead
and she's like anyone anyone no no no
choose one
how about this turk this one has two
kids
a beautiful family waiting for him at
home she's like no not this one choose
another one
and then she goes through all the life
stories of the other and since he's like
no no just
don't take anyone he's like i can't do
that i can
you can choose to bring your brother
back and he will be depressed for the
rest of his life because he didn't fight
at war
because he didn't go to that battle and
he will live without her she's like
and in the end the woman decides to have
her brother killed instead
because he dies with her i mean this is
good
so so why am i giving you these examples
it's not a glorification of misery
it's a it's expanding your emotional
range
it's teaching you that and and when i
read these stories i'm not i'm not a
jerk i'm crying out loud
i have tears and i like my face becomes
red
from the the the pain that i'm
experiencing through these stories
it's just so deeply touching
to embrace the
suffering not because
of an accident but because of a choice
the sacrifice to embrace the fact that
not everything is cute and rosy and
always ending well
and i think that we don't do a good
enough job of teaching our kids that
just life sucks and life is unfair
sometimes
and that's and that's okay and sometimes
i read a story to my kids i read a story
every night
and sometimes the story is horrible
and sometimes the story is good and and
sort of friendly and happy
and my kids always ask what's the moral
of the story
and sometimes those are moral and it's
like oh you should be good or you should
be
nice you should be helping each other et
cetera and sometimes it's just no moral
and i tell my kids you know what
sometimes just
life doesn't make sense and it's okay
and you can't comprehend everything
and i think this concept of how do you
deal with bad days
comes from the fact that we're taught
we're brainwashed into thinking that
every day should be a happy day
and we're not ready to cope with misery
and the other thing that crying through
these stories teaches you
is that you don't have it nearly half as
bad as you think
do you see do you see what i mean
basically it tells you that i mean
my mom would always tell me about how
she was transformed as a teenager when
she volunteered
in the hospital and she saw all these
people
at the brink of death clinging for life
and helping them out to be she could and
crying
her heart out when they were dying
and sort of how that taught her the
appreciation
for what we have every day waking up
every morning and saying
my life doesn't suck my life is not
nearly half as bad as it could be
and and sort of embracing the
joy that we have of living where we live
in the moment we live
and i'm gonna go further if you look at
the arc of human
life you know human existence through
the centuries
there's no better way to be alive than
now i mean we're complaining about every
single little thing
but life expectancy is at an all-time
high
sickness all-time low poorness
misery all-time low there's no better
time to be alive
globally across all of human existence
number one
number two here in boston there's no
better place to be alive
if you think about the amalgamation of
science engineering technology
the ridiculously awesome people you're
bringing every week to your podcast
i mean this is the ancient greece of
modern society
but the weather still sucks because no
let me put it this way the weather gives
us a range
of emotion the full range the full
scenic
that's such a fascinating thing about
human psychology i've i often re-read
this book i'm not sure if you're
familiar with this man's search for
meaning
by viktor frankl and uh
he talks about you know
his uh living through the holocaust and
in the concentration camps
and even there where there's like human
misery
is at its highest
even there he discovers these
moments by observing the suffering by
accepting the suffering
he he observes moments of
true joy of uh how great his life is
relative to others at the camp
uh who have it worse yeah so so
it's a it's a dangerous livery slope to
think that way because
it's basically being better than jones's
and if you know
if the house next door has a giant car
then you want to get a bigger car or
something like that
it's not comparative misery i think
the way that i see it is slightly
different it's
and it's not even thinking about all the
worst possible outcomes
that could have happened but didn't the
the example as you were talking about
the concentration camps the most
horrible
i mean one of the most horrible moments
of human existence i was thinking
about pictures that i was seeing of kids
in syria
in war-torn zones and you're looking at
these kids
and again i cried out loud
imagining my own son in the van
after a bomb explosion watching his
you know father die or his siblings die
or
losing his friends it's something that
we are not
capable of fathoming but if you actually
put a seven-year-old in that situation
the look that i saw in these kids eyes
basically said
it is what it is it was it was
and i've experienced that with my own
kid when he gets
like my my my three-year-old last
like two years ago who's now my
five-year-old
she was burned really badly with like
hot chocolate and coffee that just
peeled off her skin so you could
actually see just her fragile skin had
just peeled off
and she was the happiest little kid
she was just going along with the
punches it is what it is
it is she accepted it so so it's quite
dramatic to sort of realize that
children don't say oh i could have it
better
they they sort of
embrace the moment not embrace but sort
of accept the moment
and then they can have moments of pure
joy
in a horrendous war-torn country
and you know like so many people from
you know these
war-torn countries basically say oh you
think
you americans are going to just come and
just send us a bunch of aid and
food etc yeah sure that's helpful
but what do we dream of what do we
struggle for we struggle for love
we struggle for meaning we struggle for
you know
emotions and friendships we struggle for
the same things you guys struggle for
we're not just like every day waking up
and saying oh i wish i had more food
no that's just a given i just don't have
enough food but what we struggle with
are basically everything else and that
sort of gives you some perspective
on life it basically says you know and
another story that my mom told me when i
was a kid is this story about sort of
this
man who's basically you know see he sees
the christ appear in front of him he
says oh christ i'm carrying all these
problems i'm carrying this big bag can
you please take it from me and he's like
sure
let me just give you any other bag
and basically you know
the person in the end accepts his own
bag so acceptance
ultimately recommended acceptance
every single other bag is probably worse
it's the evil you don't know versus the
evil you know
like we all struggle with our own
problems but
if you look at the bigger picture it's
just your path through life
and if you embrace it the good and the
bad
every single day it's just
joy elation
sadness misery if you don't have both
you're not the complete human being you
know you can't i mean
the last example i'm going to give is
the movie um
inside out by pixar beautiful movie
which one is that
the one with the little characters
controlling all the emotions
so you basically have joy and sadness
and fear and disgust etc
and the moral of the story if you
remember the movie the moral of the
story
is that in the end joy is basically
trying to fix everything to make
everything happy
and she's failing miserably and
everything else is like crumbling and
falling apart
and the little girl basically becomes
emotionless because all she knows how to
do is fake happiness
and i think it's a very good analogy for
our everyday society
where we're always saying are you happy
are you happy my mom calls me and she's
like
manolas are you happy i'm like mom stop
asking this stupid question
no i'm not happy yeah what you should be
asking is if i'm fulfilled
yeah and that's a very different thing i
don't go around being happy
i wouldn't love it if your mom called
and said
manolas are you suffering beautifully or
something that's exactly right
that's what she should be asking are you
are you
struggling to achieve something great
yeah that's the question that your mom
should be asking not only did that mom
call me about the suffering not about
how good uh how good are you doing so
what i tell her
is that life is not about maximizing
happiness life is about
accomplishing something meaningful and
accomplishing that meaningful thing
cannot come from a series of joyful
moments
it comes from a series of struggles of
successes
and failures of people being nasty to
you and people being nice to you
and embracing the full thing
you